[Music]
i think it helps everybody listening and
watching to know
that you're never beyond the need for
help
you're never beyond the need for advice
and you're never beyond the need to try
some new
tools
and learn some new skills
so that you can then accommodate the
opportunities that are in front of you
[Music]
what's up all you beautiful earth
dwelling creatures and creators welcome
to another incarnation of guru
multiverse where we
wade into sacred waters both
metaphysical and practical
my co-host for this exploration is guru
singh
a master of the kundalini arts guru
singh is a good friend he's a celebrated
spiritual teacher a third generation
sikh yogi an author an accomplished
musician a father a grandfather
basically
a gift to humanity now holding virtual
court at
kundaliniuniversity.com
the guru resides in the house of the rrp
today for
a dissertation on
divining and discerning the delicate and
detailed differences that differentiate
instinct
impulse
intuition
and intelligence the four
eyes so this one is about perspective
it's about accountability
the willingness to solicit and receive
feedback and why growth depends on
your ability to truly understand and
appreciate the nuances that distinguish
these i words this might be one of my
favorite vulcan mind melts to date so
hit that subscribe button make sure to
stick around to the end once again guru
singh takes us out with the song
and that's it let us not waste another
moment this is me and garu singh
we're back again guru corner is like a
thing i know it's happening you know
with
the beauty of your of your new studio
and your dedication to doing these shows
with people in person
uh has
you know opened up
me to the idea that well i'm going to
have to be down here every few months
if for no other reason then we're we're
going to pop in and
do an hour i know you're mr internet now
and virtual and all of that and that's
fantastic with kundalini university but
there is something about the analog
experience i know you know i just
have a really hard time
uh
doing what i do
in a zoom format i can do it but is it
the same it really isn't
it isn't the same and
one of the things that i've always
treasured
about
our communication
is we watch each other you know we're
we're across a desk or across a table
looking at each other
and you and i are
a bit of an expert in body languaging
and
and we start to form our conversations
not just in the spoken word
but also in the you know the physical
expression and the facial expression you
don't get that in the two-dimensional
zoom world yeah it's much more difficult
it's much more difficult yeah and i
think that is true i mean
when i
sit down with you i have an idea of
things i want to talk about but other
than that there's no preparation which
makes this a lot easier because some of
the guests like i have to put in hours
and hours and hours of yeah prep time to
be here
um well i will interject
as an interruption
it is because
this is not an interview
this is equal partners in a conversation
and that to me
is
the greatest value that i get from our
time together
is that we're not there's not a person
who's an expert and a person who's an
interviewer
there is
two people who are exploring the world
i hope so i think that's right but if i
start to stutter or look like i can't
think of anything to say then you then
i'm giving you the visual cue to step in
and save me i do keep it going i gotta
go to point guard then
right and run the game um what i want to
talk about today
what i want to focus on is
the difference between
instinct and
impulse
when are we
following our intuition when can we
trust our intuition
when are we
basing our actions on instinct and when
are we acting impulsively and i think
there's different layers to this
on some level we kind of understand the
difference between these two things but
it quickly becomes
very subtle and difficult to parse
when you're making a decision am i doing
this impulsively have i thought this
through what is my intuition telling me
and can i trust my intuition
how reliable is my intuition
for me
i would
use
a metaphor
think of a movie set
and you've got a director
and you've got a script
what's going to be formed between the
director's ideas the actors skills
and the script
is going to be a combination of talents
and impulses
and intuitions
and instincts
and
sometimes the whole thing ends up in the
and they go cut
okay that didn't work out i thought
i was thinking it was gonna end
and what do they do when they have a
mistake
they do a new take
and the way in which
we can
like anything
learn
to trust our intuition
is by
learning how to forgive ourselves for
making really horrendous mistakes
and we can practice
you know with little insights and little
intuitive or
instinctual behaviors or impulsive
behaviors
and we can start
noting
how
how did we how did we do when we
followed that kind of a trigger
knee-jerk
response
and how was it if i instead of just
going with an impulse
i just stepped back for a moment
looked at the whole picture tried to
take as much in as possible
and then arrived at a conclusion that i
would then bank on still maybe make a
mistake
but
work with it
so
i believe there's tremendous value and
impulse
the where why and when
is going to be significant
i believe there is tremendous value in
holding impulse
and again the where why and when is
going to be important
i believe there's a significant
difference between instinct and
intuition
and we can dive deeper into that
but i think there's a place for both
what is that difference like is instinct
more
in attunement with
impulsivity
yes well to a degree
instinct
is more of a hereditary
circumstance
instinct comes out of your
out of your dna out of your physiology
it's learned behavior you know the
the capacity for
your
body to know
for example when you're on a long
distance bike ride run swim
there will be instincts that are coming
up that aren't based on just impulse
they're based on patterns that you have
remembered over many many years many
many years and they may be in some ways
patterns that you've inherited
from your mom and dad and your
grandparents and generations
that's what instincts are and instincts
are stored in the body chemistry
the idea
that you have
this body intelligence
is part of what the instinctual network
is able to employ
intuition
on the other hand
is less of physiology
and more of a subtlety base
you start to build
your intuitive skills
through
as i've said in other
ones of our interviews through the use
of the parasympathetic nervous system
the nervous system that takes a step
back
the nervous system that takes in more of
the information the data field that is
you know present in the moment
and then starts to allow the
co-relations or what's
rapidly called correlations
between the different data points
when you're in that state of the
parasympathetic
theta brain the dreamtime brain
all of a sudden and you've learned how
to get yourself into that state
you can start forming intuitive
um
determinations or decisions
that are not based on impulse but they
may take impulse into account
and so impulse doesn't control the show
but impulse gets to contribute to the
show
and instinct doesn't control the show
but instinct also contributes
and so then all of a sudden you have
impulse contributing instinct
contributing
body intelligence contributing
and
larger pictures contributing
then
as this sounds like a complexity but it
can happen ultimately very rapidly
then you can base a decision on all of
this inputs it's like a
instinct to me is like a really
successful
business leader a really successful c uh
ceo that listens to all of the input and
then comes to a conclusion that is
collective
or what is called in my world the
elevated paradox
you know you've got the all of the
issues that are competing for space
and then you've got the paradoxical
issue that just sort of arises
from that
tension and pressure
the four eyes yeah
instinct impulse intuition and
intelligence beautiful right
yeah they overlap a little bit with each
other i mean the way that i've always
thought about this is
instinct yes this is something that's
bred into our dna as animals that have
evolved over millennia
um impulse is a reflection of our
emotional bodies in the experiences and
traumas and stresses that we've had over
the course of our lifetimes we have
buttons that have been installed that
when they get pushed we act impulsively
there's not
you know a lot of neural activity in in
terms of like intelligence that comes
into play we react without thinking
about it it's only in the wake of that
action or
engaging in that impulse that we then
have to pick up the pieces or you know
figure out how we went wrong here
impulses or enjoy yeah i mean i i tend
to associate it with a negative
connotation but obviously we have
impulses for a reason and
you know back to that sympathetic
nervous system like an instinct or an
impulse can be
a way of keeping you safe or you know
avoiding danger or
you know reacting to a certain stimulus
that is you know basically creating a
boundary any of these things right yeah
just think about the impulse
as sometimes the first move
almost like first responders
and that
instinct
might be in getting the injured
to a facility
intelligence is in the analysis of
what's going on and then in the midst of
surgery
some intuition comes in
when when obstacles are met you know so
there's a place for all of that right
you said that it combines
you know those uh those graphics where
they have the con the circles
intersecting a certain program yeah and
what is that what is it the venn dot
venn diagram yes and that sweet spot
where they all
share common space
there you go yeah but intuition the way
that you characterize it
is a little bit of fairy dust a little
bit of the unknown that i love
a little bit of fairy does i think the
problem and one of the reasons why why i
wanted to talk about this with you today
is that we
can confuse
instinct or impulse with intuition and
my sense is that there are a lot of
people who are living their lives in a
manner that we described in the last
episode that we did
where
we're not so
you know we're not so connected to
ourselves we're living our lives
reactively we're
you know going to our job and waking up
and just trying to get by and we're
inoculating our selves with media etc
and there's not a lot of internal
reflection
and there's a dissonance between the
higher self and kind of the operating
system that's carrying this you know
human machine through
through life and i think
short of
really engaging in that internal work of
self-understanding this
exploration
um
that i'd like to think that i'm on and
that i know that you're on of trying to
understand ourselves and trying to
reconcile those past traumas and make
sense of them and become more
self-actualized and whole
that we
begin to
develop a sense of
the difference between
intuition and instinct in that
we
we begin to be able to trust our
intuition like one of the things
that i learned early in sobriety is that
i couldn't i couldn't trust my intuition
because my intuition had led me astray
it had been
kidnapped or co-opted by substances and
thought patterns and
behaviors that
had taken me
to some dark places like i would think
you know my instinct was oh do that or
i'm conflating these terms but my
intuition was i should do this and then
i'd end up in some terrible situation
right
so in early sobriety i didn't feel like
i could trust my intuition
and i was told that it would probably be
a good idea to not trust my intuition
until i had kind of done enough
of this work
to the point where i could dip my tail
back into that test it oh that worked
out maybe i can trust it a little bit
more trust a little bit more trust a
little bit more
to the point where now i feel very
confident in trusting my intuition but
that was not something that happened
overnight yeah
i think intuition you've just
framed it beautifully
what that what your communication just
there brought in to me was intuition is
a little bit like a pilot's license
you know there's a lot of ground skill
that you have to go through reading
and and
you know
trying things before you actually end up
up in an airplane
and so intuition is very
very real but it needs the skill set
needs to be developed
and oftentimes you said people
um
mistakenly equate
emotion
or or impulse or
instinct for intuition i think that a
lot of people
uh on a spiritual path
will will be mistaken in the opposite
direction they'll think that they're
intuitively feeling something and all
they're actually feeling is just a
really strong emotion
you know and so they're disguising
what would be impulse
by holding an emotional impulse at bay
long enough
so it feels like it's qualified to make
the decision
and
so
and it's a little bit like
you know a person that's just taught
themselves how to golf or tennis
play tennis and you know and then they
find a teacher and the teacher has to
undo everything that they've been doing
and so they get worse
at playing golf right until they get
better right
and i believe that it's the same way
with with using the four eyes
that you can use them successfully but
if you're but if you're learning how to
train the intuition to train your
instincts to come in when you need that
instinctual behavior to train the
impulse to be able to come in when you
need it i mean
driving a car
you better have some good instincts and
some good impulses because
things can fly at you right and left and
you need to be able to respond and
sometimes
really react
and then there's times when you can
follow the intelligent pathway
into the intuitive
realm
and it's successful but i certainly
wouldn't drive my car on intuition
no you'd look like an idiot on the road
i feel like this process requires
an objective
outside
[Music]
counselor like whether that's a mentor
or a spiritual guide or a teacher or
a sponsor somebody who can yes reflect
back to you
the truth of the decisions that you're
trying to make i mean a perfect example
would be
somebody who's in a string of bad
relationships and
is all ready to commit to this new guy i
know he's abusive but like i think this
is going to be different my intuition is
telling me that this is the one it's
like no that's not a well-honed
intuition that is programming built in
by dint of
a terrible relationship with your father
who modeled bad behavior and has crossed
the wires in your brain
to put you in this position where you're
attracted to that unhealthy behavior wow
until we untangle that knot and really
look at
why you keep ending up in these types of
relationships you're going to continue
to do it and you're going to delude
yourself that you're acting on your
intuition when in truth you're acting
impulsively based upon trauma and
you know
emotional circumstances that were beyond
your control at a very early age
that is profound and
you said it when you first entered
sobriety i didn't trust my intuition
that's appropriate
there's an appropriate time
if a person is sort of fixated and
addicted to bad relation because of the
programming that scrambled i'm just re
using your words that scramble the
internal relational wiring from a bad
father or a bad uncle or a bad this or a
bad that
and then
that is the time to not trust your
intuition
that is the time to try to trust and get
more in touch with your intelligent pa
your intelligence patterns
and maybe even your instinctual patterns
but have your instinctual patterns pass
through your intelligence before you act
i'm getting confused
too many eyes too many eyes
but really what you're looking at is
sometimes you have to be that witness
sometimes you have to be that guide or
that sponsor
but you're a very unreliable narrator
for your own life correct that's the
problem but there and that's the you
can't see that when you're in it right
but there are times that you can then
learn by your mistakes
and in that not seeing it when you're in
it
learning by your mistakes requires the
giving forward which is forgiving
the giving forward in order to learn
from the lesson and give yourself
forward into the new opportunities
rather than be cringed by the lesson
crushed by the lesson and forced to
never learn another lesson in that
category and just be single for your
whole life right
or whatever else is you know the
circumstance
being able to give yourself forward to
for forward give yourself to to forgive
yourself
and allow yourself to learn
to make the mistake like i said
on the movie set
cut
cut your loss but on that in that
context you have a director who is the
objective outside observer who says cut
this is not working
you're way off track here your intuition
is leading you astray yeah i think we
all need some version of that person as
a mirror as a you know a a a
a non-interested party who can reflect
back
the truth of
the decisions that you're trying to make
that's interesting that you want to do
that tell me more about why you think
that's a good idea
that that is the value of a lot of
things that's a value of having a
sponsor
in sobriety
that's the value of having a therapist
in life
that's the value of having a teacher
a counselor
that's the value of having that
that
witness
and
you know in today's world
the idea of
of a guru and by the way i'm not i'm not
selling myself here because my name is
guru singh it's not my position or title
but the idea of the guru right that the
teacher the the wise one the ones who's
the one who's been through it before
and however you however you assimilate
that
whether it's a sponsor a witness a
friend
i call it a an accountability buddy
you know i have an accountability buddy
i have an accountability buddy and my
wife i have accountability buddies in my
children
and
if i can't pass my behavior
through their eyes and through their
senses
then
i'm looking at it as inappropriate or as
as i shouldn't go down that pathway so
filling ourselves
with sponsors with
with people who are wiser than we are is
really a value added yeah i think it's i
think it's crucial i mean there's a
couple pieces to this that i think are
important for
those that are listening or watching who
haven't had the experience of being in
therapy or are not part of a
spiritual community or a 12-step
community
i think
we all have people within our
communities or in our circles that are
wiser than us in various categories so
perhaps a
a way to look at it
is as a board of advisors like when i
have a relationship problem i know this
person who's been in a healthy
relationship for 30 years like that's
the person i'm going to call to run this
problem by
or when i have a fitness or a running
question there's a different type of
person that i'm going to call not
not every guru needs to
be able to check all those categories
and i think just being in the habit
and developing the humility of running
your decisions by these types of people
is a really great practice even if it
just affirms the decision you are
already going to make
it's still a healthy habit and more
often than not
you're going to come up against some
resistance well maybe you didn't think
about this or me and they're going to
tell you that maybe you're not making
the right decision which is
uncomfortable and maybe you're going to
make that decision anyway
but maybe you'll reflect back on that
which gets to the second piece that i
wanted to talk about which is developing
the capacity to receive the feedback i
think that's the real mover here it's
one thing to have these advisors or
gurus in your life but if you can't
receive what they're telling you or
advising you of then
you're not getting off first base right
so yeah
the capacity to receive the feedback
is
um a function of
humility like can you set aside your ego
or what it is that you are so attached
to doing
and can you hear
the objective outside perspective on
why maybe that might not be the best
thing for you
and i think
that dynamic works best or optimally
when the person who's delivering the
feedback
is able to do it in a non-judgmental way
right like how can you
keep this on an even keel
the feedback deliverer
just says plainly did you think about
this maybe you should think about this
that's interesting that you want to do
that and then receive it oh rather than
get defensive which is an impulse that i
think we all have
to develop
the capacity to just
to take it in to process it and say
thank you for that let me think about
that it doesn't commit you to a certain
path but
to me that's
that's the process and that's the way
that i try to make most of the bigger
decisions that i have to make and it's
dramatically improved my life
you've you've
housed this really beautifully
what i
understand in that the way you've
described this
is that if you're feeling a lot of
discomfort
in
the recep the reception of the advice
then you can pretty much be guaranteed
that you are too impulsive mm-hmm yeah
and you could take that as oh that's an
interesting piece of information that
i'm feeling that resistance feeling
defensive
that should tell you something and and
if you're and if you're wise
you will take that
signal
and process it and say okay
i'm uncomfortable
because my impulse has already got me
moving in this direction of this choice
that i'm making and now i've asked
somebody
to give me their advice on the choice
that i'm already committed to
right my impulse is already engaged
and if that is what is occurring often
then you have to realize that you need
to put more energy into the other three
eyes
the intelligence the instinct and the
intuition
and you need to draw back a little bit
on the impulse because it's causing you
to be uncomfortable under the influence
of the advice
or the suggestions
that are coming from the witness be it a
sponsor a therapist however it is
what i learn from a lot
is the three brains the head brain the
heart brain and the gut and the gut
brain the
or m braining as as as medical science
multibraining calls it
the heart in the brain in your heart
has to work to serve
but has to surrender to receive
so if
if you sort of take that model and apply
it to
how are you going to receive the the
advice how are you going to receive the
advice of a sponsor a therapist a
witness of some form
you're going to have to surrender and
surrender doesn't mean giving up
surrender just simply means become
inactive
for a moment
it doesn't mean that the momentum is
lost it doesn't mean that anything is
lost it doesn't mean that the idea is
lost
but it means stop engaging it's like a
car
if you put in the clutch
the engine is still there all the
horsepower is still there
the wheels are still there the drive
column is still everything is still
there but it's disengaged for a moment
and maybe
in that disengagement
you will say well
i should turn the car to the hard right
because the way i was going is not going
to have a benevolent outcome because
i've talked to my
my witnesses i've talked to my people
and they're all advising me against this
or you may say
i'm good to go
i'm going to go against all advice
and but i'm going to take full
responsibility
and all of these sort of
mimicked sequences
mock sequences
need to be studied
how many of the decisions that you made
against advice over the last x amount of
time
you talked about
we can do
more in a year or no we can do less in a
year but more in a decade
um how many of the decisions that we've
acted upon against advice have turned
out
is it greater than 50 or less than 50
percent
and start coming up with some
conclusions
based on real data another way to parse
this or look at it
again i always go back to
the addiction recovery kind of lens on
these things it's beautiful one of the
things that i learned
is
evaluating these decisions or these
impulses or these intuitions
through
a calculus of
what hole am i trying to fill so if i
have this notion that pops into my head
i am feeling
very hungry
i'm protein starved i must go to
mcdonald's mcdonald's is the solution to
my problem
that is my instinct that is my gut it's
telling me
that's how i'm gonna solve this hunger
that i have
well let's deconstruct that a little bit
are you truly protein deficient what's
driving this hunger and what is the
emotional discomfort that you're feeling
right now that your unconscious
mind is telling you will be resolved by
putting a gigantic amount of
calories into your gut as quickly as
possible that will
essentially sedate you
it's an addictive response to
an emotional discomfort that's driving
that decision
thus
it is less intuition
and it is more
impulse and impulse
driven
by an unconscious emotional need
well you said the word sedation
because the unconscious emotional need
will remain
once that food is digested and digested
and wears off well you will be sedated
for a moment you will be sedated so that
you won't and your emotional
ease will return exactly
and
what is a more appropriate
view in that moment is to go okay my
impulse is this
and by asking yourself
what hole am i trying to fill
it's got many layers doesn't it
and there's many different aspects to
the whole right that is being filled
here and maybe if we just withheld some
of the consumption
and spend a little more time in the
evaluation
we might realize something that could be
reapplied over and over and over again
successfully
that ultimately ends up changing the
fact that that even comes up
that we may never have to ultimately
face that same challenge that same
emotional
need that same hole that needs to be
filled
yeah if you're constantly
reaching out to fill the hole and doing
it impulsively without any kind of
higher cognizance of what's going on
you're just going to perpetuate that
behavior
but if you take a moment
and say i'll go to mcdonald's in 20
minutes but i'm going to sit with this
emotional discomfort and try to figure
out why i'm feeling the way that i'm
feeling right now
more often than not that will lead to
some epiphany oh i just had a fight with
my spouse 20 minutes ago that's why
i feel you know uneasy right now and i'm
reaching out for this thing that i know
will fix me at least in the short term i
think the ego comes into play as well
like if somebody comes to me and they
say
i want to run a marathon like i've been
on the couch and i don't like how i feel
like this is this is what i'm gonna do
like help me figure out how to get there
and i've told this
some version of this story before so
forgive me if you've heard it but
my question to that person my first
question to that person is always
why like what is it what is the problem
that you think this is going to solve
well i just want to do it i've never
done anything
maybe that's great
or maybe
you're emotionally out of balance and
you're gonna
take on a very difficult goal
only to discover that it wasn't the
right goal for you because you're not
integrated enough
to trust
what you think is an intuition but is
really just an impulse being driven by
some discomfort that you're experiencing
sedation periods are very telling
running a marathon for example
you know requires a lot of preparation
requires a lot of effort and then
there's a recovery time
and so one of the things that about the
sedation of anything whether it's a
positive or a negative
is that what you were saying before
after the fact
the whole remains
unless the whole itself
has been discovered as to what's causing
the whole
and what you said a moment ago about
going back in time you know let's take
20 minutes you know not go out and grab
the burger and let's go back in time and
see okay what's led to this sensation
if you do that often enough
one will find through that discipline
that the sensations are in themselves
very complex
and a lot of the feelings that we feel
aren't our feelings
a lot of the feelings because we consume
through every
every orifice in our body not just you
know not just putting it into our mouth
we consume through our eyes and our ears
and our nose and everything
and a lot of times what is creating the
whole
is the fact that we are being targeted
by so many people
in the marketing world in the sales
world in the industrial world in the
financial world in the political world
etc etc all of these worlds that are
competing for our attention
on steroids now with the internet
that there is actually no hole
there is actually
a sensation that there is a hole
but if i actually get down to it i'm
good
and i don't have a hole
but if i had sedated the idea that i had
a hole i could never have been awake
enough to recognize the fact that i
don't have a hole
and that i am being inundated by those
things that can only sell me a fix the
whole solution
if i believe that i have a whole right
the idea that you are in lack
and i have the solution for that lack in
the form of product x y or z or
even healthy pursuit a b or c because
all of those things can be
inoculants
um that are driven by a sense that you
are not complete exactly the way that
you are i love that word inoculant so
i'm going to steal that man i'm just
going to use
it so i know you didn't invent it but
you really use it with me the bottom
line with me is that it even applies to
the world that i live in
right the the world of spiritual
teaching and of of healthy living and of
all those things
sometimes if a person can just go down
inside themselves learn a technique to
go down
inside themselves and evaluate
themselves they'll find out that in fact
they're okay
the way they are
it's just all of this other
paraphernalia
and so it might be more of a
reductionary
practice rather than an additive
practice let's add this to my life let's
add this to my life or maybe it's let me
subtract this from my life let me
subtract this from my life and if i do
that
not
to a place of renunciation
but to a place of at least i can see and
be more clear
that becomes
a place where i can feel
i don't have a hole
i am whole
i am complete it's hard though man it's
so much more fun to add stuff
subtracting stuff is painful of course
more meaningful ultimately but
the extent to which this game is rigged
against us is rigged i mean the lengths
that we will go myself included to avoid
just having to sit quietly
with ourselves
is insane
we'll be back in a sec but first if you
dig this podcast and i hope you dig this
podcast then i think you'll really enjoy
my latest book voicing change featuring
excerpts from poignant essays by and
glorious photography of some 50 of my
favorite guests over the last eight plus
years of doing this thing this podcast
it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the
show and copious wisdom shared therein
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table
form that provides a great taste of what
we do here at the rrp and serves as a
beautiful keepsake or gift for the
ardent fan the book is only and
exclusively available on our website
signed copies are available and we are
shipping globally direct to any coffee
table on planet earth so to learn more
and snag your copy today visit
richroll.com
vc that's
slash richrole.com
all right let's get back into it
well i remember you and i once having a
conversation around the weighted blanket
and awesome
i still sleep with it every night and
all the relationship is with that
weighted blanket is to literally force
you to not move
to to
sequester the impulse
while you're unconscious
and and it holds you in place you know
the weighted blanket is very much like
in biblical terms the swaddling clothes
and in in native indigenous terms the
papoose
where by
the child was held
and contained
and really found that the flailing of
the arms and legs or
the movement at nighttime
was what was causing the sensation of i
need to move more because that movement
didn't give me everything i need
and so
i love it because that weighted blanket
changed your world yeah and that
weighted blanket is a forced stillness
i'm just a baby that needs to be
swaddled
i love it yeah it's this calming that is
your innocence your your uh
your sympathetic nervous system it's a
feeling that
it creates this feeling of of of of of
safety right like you're okay you can
relax you can let your guard down you
don't need to be in fight or flight
all is well with the world you are
complete go to sleep now we were talking
impulse intuition instinct and
intelligence
you know impulse is a little bit like
the old biblical terminology where
such and such begets such and such more
right
using the word begets right
and and impulse
or movement
or
knee-jerk reaction
[Music]
can tend to
inflate the circumstance
and not always but when it does inflate
the circumstance and then you have to
move and become even more impulsive and
then you have to move and become even
more impulsive and so that's when i'm
just saying
that sometimes like with a weighted
blanket
if you subtract
an impulsive move
rather than enact
and just give yourself a little bit of
time
to open the brain's aperture
you know we're on camera right now where
you know opening up the aperture of that
camera is going to feed more light into
it's going to give more information into
it when we can open up the aperture of
our own mind and bring in more
information maybe that additional
information
is the circumstances which can avoid
what are often called the unintended
consequence
yeah that goes back to being receptive
to
that type of feedback when i reflect
back on
the history of the decisions that i've
made before getting sober
and then throughout my
sobriety it's very revealing like i
realize only in retrospect that
most of the decisions that i made when i
was drinking and using were purely
impulsive driven by
the idea uh that i had a hole or just a
sense of overall discomfort with myself
that
must be quelled
and i found substance as a means of
accomplishing that it worked until it
stopped working
but
in tandem with that was a drive to just
be a pleasure seeker to never
be in that
discomfort to never look at it to never
try to deconstruct it or understand it
or work through it just
make it go away as quickly as possible
for as long as possible
then you get sober
you have this explosion of emotions that
are very confusing and disorienting
and with that
i developed
the reflex to run my decisions by
other people
peers within that community
sponsor etc
and more often than not
irrespective of the feedback i would
still make the impulsive decision so i
had to do that for a period of time
and did exactly what you said which is
tally in inventory of how that worked
out my sponsor would say okay you're
gonna do what you're gonna do here's
what i you know i'm not attached to
whatever you do but here's what i think
make the wrong decision
suffer the circumstances of that
reflect upon it do it again do it again
do it again do it again
until my actions started to align
with the feedback that i was getting and
i started to notice that
my impulses were becoming more intuitive
and the decisions that i was exploring
were more
consistently aligned with the feedback
that i was getting instead of getting
feedback that made me defensive because
this person was telling me i shouldn't
do the thing that i
want to do or kind of already had
decided that i was going to do the
feedback was
saying yeah i think that's a good
decision or go for that
then i reached a sort of rubicon with
the whole thing where
where
i wanted to explore
myself as an athlete
it's like i think i want to do this
ultraman race i mean for an addict or an
alcoholic to be like i've never done an
iron man but i'm going to go do this
double iron man any sponsor is going to
tell you like that's probably not a good
idea or i think maybe you're out of
alignment or perhaps you should you know
reflect on that a little bit more
but that was a situation in which
i felt
confident and comfortable in my
intuition even though it didn't match up
with the feedback that i was getting
because i'd done
10 plus years of work to get to that
point
and i didn't have any guilt
in making the decision to to pursue that
even though
it wasn't in alignment with the feedback
that i was getting
how'd that work at the point and it
worked it changed my life and it was
great and i you know so
but
the important piece in that whole thing
is all the work
that went into getting to that place
where i could then
go my own way and feel confident and
comfortable
that my intuition was guiding me rather
than handicapping me oh man
i love
that experience that you just took me
through because
let's apply it to the world of
of having advisors
having a guru having a teacher having a
therapist having this having that
it can't be
a forever kind of event
as a only source
of your well-being
there has to come a place where you are
self-reliant
and it doesn't mean that you throw away
the advisors
and just
go it on your own
but it means that you are able to
create a segway
between the advice
and what you believe
is your own
budding intuition
that you are starting to become
wiser
more intelligent
less impulsive
and if you can
build that trust
over time
by
going it your way making a mistake
forgiving yourself picking yourself back
up
acknowledging that you could use a
little more advice before you go out and
do it your own way again
and then when you do finally get to that
place where you can begin to trust
your own intuitive your own inner sense
that's what gives you the strength
and that is what the idea of a teacher a
guru a therapist a
a sponsor a witness
anything
is all about
people in the world of
therapy people in the world of
of uh spirituality people in the world
of any number of things
will sometimes get locked into a
you know a one perspective
is what i always go to i always go to
this person i always go to this for this
person knows best for me and like you
said previously
you would go to somebody different for
marriage counseling than you might for
running counseling
as to what's the best way to go forward
and that's the same kind of trap that we
can get we can get addicted to our
advisor mm-hmm well also there's an
identity that gets baked into that yes
as well this is a teacher student
person who follows this person or
i'm an adoptee of certain you know this
of philosophy acts or spiritual vein why
or i am or i can only make my decisions
if my therapist slash my sponsor slash
agree with me
and that provides
uh if we can use the metaphor a muscular
atrophy in that self-reliance
the student must leave the nest at some
point exactly and
and so in in these worlds of
advisory and in these worlds of building
the intuitive muscle and building in in
reducing the impulsive nature and
balancing it out with the other three
eyes
this world has to become a world
ultimately
of self-reliance that is still willing
to be a student
still willing to receive that incredible
hey i i think about that if i were you i
know you've been doing this for a lot of
time but i'm just looking from a
different angle and i'm not seeing it
a great litmus test for
uh trying to understand whether
you're being driven by impulse or
intuition is the 24-hour rule
if you have a decision to make
if you need to send somebody an email
that's perhaps incendiary
sit on it for 24 hours and see if you
feel the same way the following day for
48 hours or so
rules and rates right if if
48 hours later you realize like yeah i
probably shouldn't send that email to
that guy even though i felt so strongly
about it the day before then you can be
assured that that was an impulsive
response to some stimuli
versus
48 hours later you're like i still think
this is a good idea can i wait another
day
well i kind of
maybe i can maybe should i can't if you
can like the longer you can push it off
and still feel confident that that's
in your best interest then you're
tipping more into the intuition area
you just hit the magic number
which is actually
physiologically and neurologically 72
hours
perspective
changes
every 72 hours obviously you have
multiple perspectives going on all at
once so it's not like every 72 hours
you're a different framework
but
you're working with a particular
perspective
when you want to send that email
this is what you want to achieve with
the email this is what you want to say
in the email this is why you want to say
it because this is what this person did
from a perspective
72 hours three days
if you can wait because you said 48
hours and then you said can you wait
another day
24 plus 48 72 hours in three days that's
a magic number and that's not like
that's not like philosophy that's like
actual physiology
what i
experience i'm sure this is very common
like i'll get an email that will
throw me off kilter
and i'm so uncomfortable i feel like i
have to respond to it immediately or
you're not real i just can't move
forward with anything in my life
anything else in my life until i deal
with this thing yes yes yes every fiber
of my being is like respond now or
something and that's
feeling like really fierce intuition and
the higher version of myself is like
step away from the computer you know and
it takes everything to do that yeah
yeah
i love this because
this is when we mistake
impulse
for intuition
you know there is the
you can't let anyone get away with that
trigger
if i wait 72 hours
i'm a
i'm a weakling because i've let somebody
walk on me
actually
you've let someone trigger
the actual thing that's going to walk on
you
which is the result of your impulse
that's what's going to ultimately walk
on you however
if waiting 72 hours and your perspective
is still locked in then most likely
what you're experiencing is your
intuition
go for it
but i would reckon to say that if you
kept a tabulation
of how many times
you waited 72 hours and the result was
effective
and how many times you didn't wait 72
hours or even 24 hours
and the effect was
inappropriate that you would find out
that it's way more weighted towards the
step away
from the computer oh i mean a hundred
percent of the time 72 hours later
you're like yeah i don't need i i'm so
glad i didn't send that or i don't feel
like i need to do
anything
why should i give that person so much
power you know
and also intuition
has this ability of seeing beyond time
and
if i wait 72 hours on a on a reaction to
make it more of a response
an ability to respond becoming more
responsible
you know then
what i often times experience is
what caused that person to send me that
email in the first place
and that it wasn't even me
that in that 72 hours i will have
learned a lot more about the
circumstance
and
sometimes within that 72 hours they'll
come back to me and say
you know
i really want you to disregard what i
said the other day because i was feeling
this because of this this this and this
and it really had nothing to do with you
but you were the tallest tree in the
forest and so my wind hit you
and those are the rewards that are so
incredible when you do wait
and step away from the reaction
how different would the world look if
twitter had a 72 hour delay on every
tweet that you post it and it doesn't
close and you've been in that 72 hours
you can withdraw it you can withdraw it
i mean obviously like it's supposed to
be a real time
news platform as much as anything else
it's not
functional you know that would never
happen but i feel like if it was an
option like if you could install
uh oh cool you know a preference where
every time i tweet or respond maybe just
when you're responding to other people's
tweets can weight 72 yeah maybe we
alleviate a lot of the
pain that we're causing each other on
these platforms yeah a lot of the the
the mud slinging stone through because
that is the ultimate
impulse provocateur
you read something i have to tell that
person they're wrong or
some emotional overwhelm occurs where
i must be heard on this thing now
just to as an example
i i established a i don't respond i
don't react
because
on social media
no matter
no matter how
no matter how high your intentions are
somebody will find issue with something
that you're doing who do you think
you're talking to yeah
all day long yeah yeah and so i i
appreciate that
and
and so i just i just created an inner
and an inner attitude that
i am not going to bite the bait somebody
once told me i'm a pisces right pisces
is the two fish
and some wise uh vedic astrologer once
told me that the pisces the pisces will
die by the bait and the hook
and so
i took that to heart and determined that
i wasn't going to bite the bait
i was going to wait and see
if that was really food or if that was a
hook that was trying to entangle me
and that one decision that i made and
the fact that i'm able to discipline
myself and follow that decision has made
a big difference in my life on social
media
i'm not there yet
oh yeah you are no no no i mean i i have
far more you have far more bait hanging
out there but i mean i i i
battle with the the tension between
being a broadcaster on these platforms
and being somebody who wants to be
engaged in the communities that are you
know coalescing around this work that
i'm doing and i want to be
present and i want to make myself
available to constructive
criticism and feedback but there's also
a dopamine inducing you know addictive
piece to this where it's like i have to
see these comments and then i'm exposed
to all kinds of negativity and then i
find it very difficult to emerge out of
the haze of all of that like i don't
know that it's
doing anything positive and perhaps all
would be better if i just took a step
back and used it simply like you do to
broadcast and find other ways of
cultivating community or being being
engaged with the people who are
interested in what i'm doing here
outside the four walls of these
platforms that
have become toxic for so many reasons
well i would say that
there is a moment in the race
in which every
cell in your body is screaming at you to
quit
and
kind of like hitting the wall
if
in responding
[Music]
to
negativity
you have the same discipline
that you do that has made you
a successful
st
runner bicyclist swimmer
with everything else that goes on you're
a tr you're a vegan triathlete
that if you could use the same
deflectors
like
aikido that has no offensive move
but uses the energy that's being thrown
at you
to reverse onto itself
if you develop that skill set
then you would be a person in demand
even more so than you are
because
the old saying the tallest tree catches
the most wind
and you are in the industry you are a
tall tree
in my industry i am a tall tree
and we both catch both
nourishment through the roots
and we catch wind at the top
what i do is i develop
a skill set
that allows me
particularly during these times of
scandal and and pandemic and all of
these things where people are throwing a
lot more stuff at
those of us that are putting ourselves
out there than ever before
but i find that if i
look at the opposition like an aikido
master would that that's just energy
that isn't actually opposing me that's
going to energize me
then i have to figure out okay that's a
philosophy
what's the practicality how can i
actually achieve that
and therefore i would the 24-hour rule
maybe not in social media you have a
72-hour rule because you may be way
behind the curve then but at least have
a 24-hour rule and if and if and if
nothing else have a 12-hour rule you
know on certain things but also have
ways in which you can become less
personal because there has to be an an
opportunity within your own nervous
system
to be able to take the criticism which
is obviously not
personal because nobody except a few
people know you
so they can't say they can't say who you
are or what you've done
and make it less personal
and it ultimately becomes more of a
teaching mechanism because that's what
you're doing all the time i mean
you don't have the kind of following
that you have
because you're an authority you have the
following because you love
authorities
and you gather authorities together and
people know that if you want to know
something about anything
go to the ritual podcast and look
through it and you will find because
he's got an admiration
and maybe i don't want to use the word
authority he's got admiration for wisdom
he's got admiration for people who are
very intuitive who are very intelligent
and that's
and then you present those things
and for some of those things you get
deep negative feedback
and in that way
you apply the art of aikido which simply
means no offensive moves it's the dow of
no offensive moves
and you understand that you presented
something
somebody had a bad experience with it
but that wasn't about you
of the one or two thousand people that
had a bad experience with it
there were
50 70 100 000 who had a really good
experience from it and so the ratio is
still
super positive
i'll try to bear that in mind you've got
to because you're doing such incredible
work
such a people pleaser though i have so
many insecurities around this that i
fall prey to uh
you know seeking validation in the wrong
places because i still delude myself
into that belief that there is a hole
that must be filled and chasing
the fulfillment of that hole in all the
wrong places and i'm just calling myself
out as a human being
that
when i'm not spiritually fit i can find
myself
doing that and it always leads to a not
so good place
well let let us both call ourselves
out in this moment
just so that the audience that is
watching or listening can understand
that happens to all of us
this last year
i've had to learn a lot of new tools to
deal with depression
i've had to learn a lot of new tools
to deal with
pushback really negative pushback
and so i think it helps everybody
listening and watching to know
that you're never beyond the need for
help
you're never beyond the need for advice
and you're never beyond the need to try
some new
tools
and learn some new skills
so that you can then accommodate the
opportunities that are in front of you
because as they often say
you know all the negative is is just the
positive with its ass in forward
and it all begins with a commitment to
hone that intuition and to do that
we need teachers
we need advisors
we need humility we need curiosity
we need wisdom we need gurus and a good
place to begin that journey and we need
forgiveness this might be forgiveness
compassion gratitude and we can go on
forever yeah but if you're interested in
beginning
that process perhaps a good place to
start would be
the kundalini university yeah
all of a sudden is that for a plug all
of a sudden we're gonna i'm gonna
yeah
we do teach we teach emotional
well-being
we teach mental well-being we teach
physical well-being through the science
of
the ancient science of kundalini yoga
and meditation
and also through other things too the
the spiritual world the the emotional
world the mental world the physical
world uh kundaliniuniversity.com
and
it it it's it's not the only school i'm
not even gonna say to anybody out there
that it's the best school but it's my
school so it's the school that i'm gonna
promote but i'm not going to try to
promote it by putting anything else down
it has an opportunity
and if you and if you look us up you'll
see that there's so many ways in which
you can engage us whether it's a simple
in the simple freedom of a daily
reminder or the larger investment of a
of a 16 week 200 hour course
i love the daily emails
sometimes i'm like
another one of these i don't have time
to read this i know
people have told me that and it doesn't
hurt my feelings but just the fact that
it's
another one sometimes i don't have time
to write it i'm in a bad mood delete
like i just can't do it today yeah i
love it
the next day there it is you got it just
it's always showing up no matter what
isn't that the beauty the beauty of the
of the digital age
is really
more important than the negativity of
the digital age because it is
it is so it is so consistent
yeah it doesn't have an emotional
letdown no
it always shows up relentless
relentlessly
well always
a treat and a pleasure to talk to you my
friend thank you for embracing us with
your presence
we'll do it again sometimes again soon
and uh until then
peace
gratitude
and take us out with a song yeah i'd
love to cool
i'd love to
look at jason he's all fired up to be a
music tech yeah
guitar tech
it's so good
oh you know
some great friends of mine every
kundalini class ends with this some
great friends of mine in the the
incredible string band way back in the
1960s
wrote a around a song in the round you
know
and
the the refrain to it was
may the long time sun
[Music]
shine down upon you
all
everlasting love and joy surround you
and the pure
light
the pure light within you
[Music]
guide your way on
you